this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
it's alarming new body cam video
released from metro just a short time
ago from a shootout involving police
earlier this week a suspect was killed
two officers injured good afternoon
thanks so much for joining us at 4 i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casadas
will metro police just wrapped up the
press conference just moments ago
victoria zaha was there she joins us
live now with the new details just
revealed about this case
yeah this was all unfolding as police
were issuing a search warrant related to
a murder back in november but we just
learned from metro police that person
that was shot and killed by by police on
monday was not connected to that murder
this is 19 year old isaiah tyree
williams he's the man who was killed in
an officer-involved shooting on monday
police originally went to the apartment
complex near nellison valley drive to
issue a search warrant related to a
november murder metro says they made it
loud and clear they were police before
entering the apartment but you can see
in this body cam footage williams was
right by the door on the couch and fired
at police as soon as they entered metro
officers say williams fired 18 rounds at
police and between the five officers 23
rounds were fired back at williams
kerry coogler was the first to enter the
apartment and was shot multiple times by
williams
officer cooper fired one round before
falling to the ground
this image is from officer kubler's
bulletproof vest he was shot multiple
times with three bullets struck him he
is recovering at the hospital police say
they were at that right address the
suspect in that murder case for that
search warrant was later arrested but
police weren't telling us exactly how or
give us any details but more information
is expected to come out later today
reporting live by metro victoria saha
live local now